the government has basically been
actively trying to destroy three great
companies and yeah it comes down to
money
Tesla uber and airbnb so they're all
doing interesting innovative new
business models that are changing the
way people communicate and commerce so
let's look at some info about three of
them and then I'll explain further so if
you don't know about Tesla they built an
electric car that people actually want
to buy there's a lot of them here in LA
they boldly sell directly to their
wealthy customers rather than subjecting
them to auto dealerships which helps
keep the cost down it gets rid of the
middleman and because auto dealers
account for as much as 20 percent of the
state sales tax legislators work against
them that was happening in New Jersey as
here we go New Jersey Legislature added
more burdens to rules already banning
direct sales of cars to customers
now Tesla's effectively can't be sold in
New Jersey so this is an electric car
that we talk about all the time and what
are we doing we're regulating it into
oblivion let's look at the next one uber
which we have here and I used last night
it's an app driven car service that
connects drivers and riders and minutes
it presents a threat to traditional
taxis and ride services obviously rather
than fight for customers by cutting
fares or increasing the number of cabs
taxi commissioners and City Council's
are instead trying to regulate uber out
of business on the grounds that it
provides unfair and unsafe competition
yeah because the taxi guys had a
monopoly and now they're not happy that
because of our apps we can figure out a
way to do this cheaper and more
pleasantly actually and then finally
Airbnb which is web site that allows
people to rent out apartments and homes
therefore despised by conventional
hotels and cities who rely on travelers
and tourists taxes
Austin charges hosts an annual licensing
fee and limits the number of
participants Portland has banned it in
residential neighborhoods rent
controlled advocates in New York City
are teaming with up with the hospitality
industry to try to shut it down okay so
basically what you have here are sort of
three crowd source than an away crowd
funded businesses that are making better
products that people want and what's
happening of course the government is
jumping in and trying to tax them away
the Airbnb one is the easiest example I
think because the
hotel lobby is powerful and they don't
want people being able to rent their
rooms easily you you own your room I'm
pretty sure even if you're renting
you're allowed to rent your room out
usually what do we do in a situation
like this because these are do you guys
use these three any combination of these
three things yeah used uber used Airbnb
uber is actually really it's it's a
great app that an easy way to get from
point A to point B and one of the things
especially if you're a woman is you can
read these reviews of drivers and you
feel a little bit safer and another
great thing is that drivers can then
review passengers to not to pick up
so-and-so because he was a rowdy pasture
a passenger she was a rowdy passenger
this isn't I mean government has done
this throughout history and this is such
a complex issue I me thinking about
Tesla this isn't the first time that
we've tried to kill an electric car this
is happening again and and this is all
gonna tie into the things that we've
been talking about think about media
being owned by these major corporations
think about Tesla you had a couple of
Tesla's that caught on fire for
different reasons and it became this
huge news story that they're suddenly
unsafe and the number of Tesla's that
actually caught on fire minuscule
compared to other cars and all of this
kind of stuff is interconnected all of
this kind of stuff is all about taxpayer
dollars it's all about lobbyists it's
all about the money that's going into
fund these campaigns it's all this stuff
that we have actually been talking about
and it is complicated it's not just
about these apps this stretch is pretty
far yeah so Jimmy I hate to beat our
money in politics thing again but this
is this is like a very personal example
I think it's different than the
political example of our politicians
being bought bought off for some foreign
policy interest or something like that
this one
uber should be allowed to exist should
it not well I was always taught that the
definition of fascism is when that
government and corporations collude to
screw the workers right is that that's
pretty much right so so that's what's
happening here
so that's what this is right so we've
come up with something that helps the
consumer and the government steps in and
says nah it hurts the business so we're
not we're gonna protect the business and
not the concern at the citizen which is
the same thing that happened when senior
citizens were going to Canada to get
cheaper prescription drugs because
Canada does a very sane
negotiates the decryption drugs prices
with the pharmaceutical companies which
the United States does not do so they
would go there to get them cheaper the
government then stepped in because the
pharmaceutical said hey we're losing
money from these people buying it
cheaper in Canada so the government did
do that and that is the definition of
fascism and by the way we should note
that it's not that they're colluding
just with business it's a certain type
of business because these are businesses
that pay taxes but they're not the ones
that are on the end with the politicians
right so it's actually it's more
nefarious even than just saying it's
fascism because it's not just about
business because these are businesses -
the government could be in business with
them but they're in business with their
old guys and that's even more perverse
in a way you know what I mean we've sort
of evolved and have these great three
great things an electric frickin car
that we've all been waiting for and the
government is still figuring out a way
to how do we quash this thing yeah I
mean think about it it's happened it's
happened throughout history politics
doesn't stay in touch with exactly what
the people are are moving forward with
and this is another you know prime
example of it and hopefully now because
we are interconnected and we're using
apps that we all will as as citizens
that I'm gonna try to be positive here
because I don't want come on I don't
want to be you know depressed throughout
my entire life
or my entire day but hopefully we can
and what we should do is is speak out as
voters and speak out as as consumers I
mean Adam Smith said it it's the free
hand the free market if we all are
moving in that direction
don't cab drivers don't don't hotels
don't other people have to step up their
game shouldn't they have to step up
their game and I would love to think so
that I can sleep at night and wake up
and you know not want to cry and stay in
bed I would like to think that we do and
that we can try to have some level of of
control over it as consumers because
these these businesses are going to
continue making money and government and
politics as is usual they have to catch
up and they are always 20 years behind
so to that point is is the saving grace
of this do we need frickin Facebook to
come in and buy uber because Facebook
could potentially fight the government a
little bit you know you mean they'd have
the money and the lawyers maybe like
somehow these giant corporations are
they going to be the one stuff to buy
the cool things to push out the middle
guy well I mean that certainly sounds
like one solution to that sounds like a
horrible solution yeah it's just like
what we need set we need to have we need
a benevolent corporation to fight
against a nefarious government that
doesn't seem right
right and by the way Facebook not so
benevolent not that but it right so they
all seem to be their hands are all dirty
and yeah I mean we're another Teddy
Roosevelt you know we need a guy to come
in and bust up the trust and get the
government back to the people